let's go next to Grant from Iowa City
Grant welcome to the show what's going
on
hey David so I am about a decade late
and asking this question okay but I
haven't really paid attention to
politics uh up until the last couple
years ago okay anyway
um I was thinking back to Obama's
presidency and how there was such
drama surrounding his birth certificate
and all that of course and I was curious
um how what's your perspective on a
requirement for people to be natural
born citizens in order to be eligible
for president yeah
this a little bit before I mean listen
um I I am more in the direction of
naturalized citizens should be eligible
primarily for the reason that without
that you really are creating sort of two
tiers of citizens you've got everybody's
a citizen on paper but some are kind of
like more citizens than others if that
makes sense now I do think that it would
be reasonable to say naturalized
citizens can be president but you you
have to have some additional you know
you've lived in the U.S for x amount of
years I'm completely open to something
like that but I mean listen not that I
have any interest in running for
president I was five when I moved to the
United States I've been here more than
30 years
does it really make sense for me not to
be allowed to be president on that basis
I mean I grew up here uh I've only voted
here I've only worked here I don't know
it just it it doesn't really seem like
that's that that's problematic but I am
fine with there being some requirement
where you know you you if you've only
been here uh if you're only been a
citizen for a year maybe you can't be
president but I'll have to tell you I
also understand the argument of just
letting the people decide if the voters
say hey you know what even though this
person's a citizen they've only been a
citizen a year I don't think that that's
who we need as president you could also
make the case that you don't even really
need a rule it should just be up to the
voters to decide so yeah for me I am
significantly in the direction of
allowing naturalized citizens to run for
president
right that makes sense to me too because
I can completely understand I think the
current requirement is you have to live
in the U.S for 14 years or be a citizen
for 14 years and you have to be 35 and
like that makes sense to me uh the 35
years years old is of an arbitrary
number but yeah I guess it's
understandable you want people to have
life experience that makes sense to me
but
yeah the idea that you have to be a
natural born citizen is some people you
literally can't uh
it's not an option for people to have
like like for yourself and I know you do
not plan to run but um like everyone has
the uh at least possibility of living in
the U.S for 18 years if you have the
funds to make it here and and you know
make the move yeah but you can't go back
in history and be born somewhere else
that's for sure right exactly yeah so
all right grant well thank you I
appreciate the question
I asked one um extra little thing here
oh sure
sure
um do you see there being a possibility
of that requirement being changed in the
future would is that something that
could be
Worcester is it too uh sure yeah I mean
I I see a possibility of it although it
doesn't seem like there's really any big
movement that's getting attention
pushing for it right now so I wouldn't
expect it to happen anytime soon
okay
very good all right well thanks for
taking my call all right thanks Grant
there's Grant from Iowa City with a very
important question which everyone will
say my opinion doesn't matter because
I'm biased or something like that well
then listen to someone else's opinion
let's go to Smitty from Los Angeles
Smitty what's going on
good morning David how are you I'm doing
well sorry
don't cut me off
[Music]
um
sorry I didn't mean this habit
um well I just want to say after as I've
continued to listen to you I have
discovered that pretty much my politics
are exactly where yours is at wow I mean
I I definitely feel like you know
there's just certain things that
you know that we need to take a hold of
from a public perspective with
um education with environment with you
know just certain industries that we
should really have more
you know control over from the
government perspective with a lot of
accountability I think one of the issues
is also accountability
um
and this is my question do you think it
really is so much about left and right
or do you think it really is more about
accountability and do you think that
it really is a matter of how you
structure
your society that really having that
accountability behind it so
could you be a capitalist society as
long as there's like a lot of
accountability
or could you have a more socialist
society with a lot of accountability I
feel like we do ourselves an injustice
playing this Left Right game I think
it's more about that than it is about
you know other stuff that isn't I I
don't know that I would say it's really
about accountability I mean on many
issues it is about where you are on the
political Spectrum
you know a woman's right to choose I
don't think it's about accountability
now what I will say is like for example
for many right Wingers who oppose
abortion being legal
they like to take this approach of well
it's about accountability in that if you
engage in the type of sexual activity
that leads to a pregnancy you have to be
accountable by then carrying the
pregnancy to term but I don't think
that's the type of accountability you're
talking about
um
I'm sorry it's more on the um you know
the economical side I definitely like
far you know far left on people should
be allowed to do what they do and yeah
no I wasn't suggesting they were taking
any particular position on abortion no I
don't I don't think I'm there I don't
think I'm there on accountability you
know a lot of times there's this
Instinct sometimes and I'd say this not
to criticize you but because a lot of
people do this there's this instinct to
find sort of like the grand thing that
explains everything so often in society
where people will come and they'll say
you know
fundamentally all politics is about
campaign finance and it's like well a
lot of it is but there's also a lot of
other stuff that's not about that and
sometimes people will call in and
they'll say something like what you're
saying you know fundamentally it's not
really about left right it's about
accountability I think the the world is
so complicated that I wouldn't even
waste time looking for the one thing
that it's really about everything is
about a lot of different things and I
think that's the approach we should have
okay let's do the note I do think the
accountability is definitely a big part
of it but all right but yes I think all
your points so thank you for your
feedback all right Smitty from La great
to hear from you always appreciate it
let's go to I hope I pronounced this
correctly is this is it fit Phineas or
pineus from Kansas how do you pronounce
that
hi David uh it's Phineas Phineas it's
actually based on Phineas Gage well
welcome to the program see you today sir
uh I wanted to say first and foremost
love the program huge fan uh I wanted to
ask why certain Democratic entities
would spend money specifically I'm in
Kansas why they would spend money to get
people to turn out for uh an abortion
vote but then turn around and not invest
any money in like a governor race or our
Senate race
oh uh well because they see so so you're
saying why would they spend money
advertising that there is like a ballot
initiative on abortion or a referendum
and then right the very same people
don't invest in like saying go vote for
this gubernatorial candidate who might
have a similar view on abortion for
example
the results of the recent Kansas
election and say Hey you know we got
favorable results and then turn around
abandon has come midterms I have no idea
you'd have to ask them I think I'm just
not really I'm not really sure why you
know why other people would or would not
spend money in a certain way I'm not
really sure I mean there are some groups
that only work on ballot initiatives in
referenda and then don't work on
candidate races but I I don't I think I
I just don't have all the information to
be able to give you an explanation
thank you very much Dave all right
Phineas sounds like you've got a lot
going on there in Kansas so I will let
you go